hello I'm Donna Friesen one of the many
things in short supply these days apart
from toilet paper and frozen peas is
humor it's hard to laugh when there's
this invisible virus lurking and there
are all these limits on where we can go
and what we can do and if you are sick
or if you've lost a loved one this is
not a funny time we're going to get into
much of that including the crisis inside
hundreds of care homes we worry for our
families our physical health and our
financial health and that mental health
experts say could create a looming echo
pandemic of mental health issues
it's why Ottawa and the provinces have
launched initiatives to help us cope
with this new reality and that's where
we want to start tonight our well being
and how we can get through this together
because the coronavirus should not put a
stop to our collective sense of humor
more about me I'm training for a 1k
Jessica Holmes has been doing comedy for
a few decades now you should set
achievable goals is what the experts say
and so I'm just and I'm not gonna rush
it I just had a baby eight years ago
known for her celebrity impersonations
whether it's a Spice Girl I'm Geri
Halliwell but I don't have to say that
to you because you know I'm very famous
or Celine Dion she's become famous not
only for her impersonations
but for this confession hi I'm Jessica
home I'm a comedian I've experienced
postpartum depression and regular
run-of-the-mill garden-variety
depression neither was both thoughts she
wrote a book about it depression the
comedy a tale of perseverance running if
my meditation meditation and my
meditation because I had the world's
shortest attention span and now she like
the rest of us is trying to find the
funny side of life in lockdown
and imagining how celebrities are coping
and there's the harsh reality of
personal grooming hey guys I'm coming to
you from the future time travel is
possible and you don't need to buy any
more toilet paper what I wouldn't mind
is if someone picked up a pair of
tweezers tweezers just remember to pick
those up and Jessica Holmes is at her
home in Toronto Jessica you are looking
fantastic
this pandemic is really exposed though
how we all really look right how is the
personal grooming going well you know
what I only get out of my onesie once a
week you you go all out
you look fantastic and you were telling
me that you had your kids help with your
look a little bit yeah one of my kids
did my root color in preparation what we
didn't do was take down our Christmas
tree in quarantine comedy can be
cathartic in dark times how do you find
humor in the midst of all this anxiety
as comedians say tragedy plus time
equals comedy or stress plus time equals
comedy so I have just learned to always
look for the funny and things to always
imagine where is the laugh track if my
life was a sitcom right now where would
the laugh track be and that way it kind
of takes the sting out of things and and
knowing also that you know a few months
down the road this will all be
punchlines to late-night jokes and stuff
for me life is just easier that way when
you're looking for it you've been very
open to Jessica about your own
depression and you got through it with
therapy and medication and building
healthy habits how are you handling life
right now in this weird normal and what
would you say to other people who also
have gone through depression how they
should handle the moment we're in
absolutely to anyone who is feeling
triggered by what's happening now I'm so
sorry
we will get through this a year from now
life will be calm again
it is triggering the social isolation of
it is triggering not having our regular
routine so I would just say to people
hang on I promise things are going to
get better we're gonna feel better as we
get more and more used to this way of
life what's the funniest thing you find
or have heard about the surreal
situation that we're all in I've loved
seeing how families are reacting to
what's going on and my favorite was this
viral video that came out of England of
a family taking on the characters of
Lynn is was you can see that they had
rehearsed it all day and even the
youngest kids had their parts to play so
I think it is a unifying experience
right now for people who find themselves
at home what with nowhere to go there's
a lot of boredom and you know we can
only watch so much Netflix is boredom a
breeding ground for humour Donna it is
absolutely a breeding ground for that
and within two days of the isolation
happening I had my eyebrow pencil out it
was drawn on a tiger King sort of a
beard and mustache and that has been my
life just dressing up his characters
different days or trying to find out
what are other comedians online doing
for me it's so beautiful to see how we
come together through comedy how
regardless of how people feel
politically and so on that this kind of
brings us together we're all in it
together and comedy can break the
tension beautifully
[Music]